what up guys first and foremost we want
to thank everyone that has supported us
on patreon for the last couple of years
if you didn't even know that we had a
patreon you're gonna want to listen to
this because this year we thought of a
bunch of different ways to bring us all
closer together yup we've completely
reorganized the tears so that we can get
closer and interact more with each other
starting with our first tier only
friends you get access to our private
Discord which means we get to chat every
single day how you doing you can ask us
any question on whatever you want and if
the question is good enough to turn into
a full-blown YouTube video we're gonna
give you a shout out at the end yo Roy
good job
in this tier you also get to watch our
patreon live stream recordings after we
record them and the public doesn't get
to do that and of course just like
always every once in a while a video
that's too crazy for YouTube our second
tier is only homies you obviously get
all the above plus you get to tune in to
the patreon live stream live as it's
happening this is gonna be exclusive to
only homies that tune in while it's
happening and watch it like a live
audience wow our highest tier is Only
Lovers not only do you get all of the
above but you can actually participate
in the live stream where we video chat
with each other in real time also since
you're a lover you get to kick it with
jk4 a day after being a lover for 12
months you can get a private tour of all
of our Brands like barbell joombie or
join us on our next JK Adventure you'll
also be named as a producer in the
credits for loving us so much as you you
guys know our patreon members has helped
us so much through all of our ups and
downs especially dealing with YouTube
after all these years so we wanted to
find more ways to return that love yeah
we really appreciate you guys if you
want to get closer to us and support hit
the link in the description and go to
our patreon thank you for all the love
and we'll continue to provide you with
laughter all year long
and if not stay on YouTube don't matter
have a good time
[Music]
so welcome back to another very special
episode of the careful boys where we are
currently off of the Riker feeling I
knew it
[Applause]
today we're talking about today we're
talking about something surprising that
you feared as a child oh oh my God oh my
God oh nice I don't know what the [__]
this is but I was so [__] scared of
seeing red
white black and yellow that sounds OCD
as [__] wait wait what colors red white
black and yellow that's a coral snake
the German flag yeah yeah like a coral
snake so like I don't know why when I
saw those colors as a kid it was like oh
make me feel weird and my mom's closet
um I nailed it my mom had like these
clothes that would be like those colors
together and every time I walked by the
bathroom and she left the sliding door
of the Closet open it would make me feel
like oh that's so specific it's so weird
it's so weird you think you're
reincarnated
and you got bit by a coral snake and
died or you were a German
that's German flag oh that's the current
that's Medieval Times
wow what is that
wow I thought you meant the Nazi flag
German national flag for sure German but
Medieval Times is pretty good
isn't it vertical isn't a German like
car called the Euro Car is like it's
like it's vertical colors yeah see no no
no it's um it's a horizontal [__]
it's that's the that's the flag from
1913 to 1939 you know this yeah yeah
yeah and what's the 1941 I don't know
yeah you're talking about this baby see
yeah yeah yeah that's what I'm talking
about no it's a tri-color now yeah see
but that
as a kid I would see that it would make
me feel like like I saw [__] monsters
aren't those the colors of Cobra Kai
that's random what's the uh synapses
what's up with that ever since I was
like
maybe like five or six it felt weird for
me um I was picking up dog [__] and all
of a sudden I just got so disgusted and
it killed my like appetite and I just
didn't want to pick up dog [__] anymore
and after that I was just I just every
single time like I'm eating like my
favorite meal and I'm thinking about dog
[__] and I'm like
I can't eat anymore mom and she goes you
[__] got your you better finish your
[__] you know there's starving kids in
poor countries that would love to have
my I'm like I just keep thinking about
[__] like I can't stop thinking about
dog [__] like I love my dog but I don't
want to pick up his dog [__] anymore and
I I was like I can't do it and then like
so I'm supposed to pick up the dog [__]
and it'll be days so my nightmare is
even crazier because I go to his [__]
corner and now there's so much [__] and
I'm just looking at it like wow like
this is even worse than I thought and I
just didn't want to do it my dad just
did it for me and then and I don't know
I just had a [__] phobia like it was so
bad you know what's crazy when you're a
kid and you have a dog right and you
know you're supposed to pick up the [__]
every day but when you don't by the time
you do it's so much holy you're like
holy [__] these dogs when they're
[__] they're like dollar cost
averaging and it really adds up that's
so much [__] simple lesson in investing
you're [__] DCA in their [__] [__]
every day losses one day it's not bad
and he's but he come back a week later
that's [__] the whole backyard you're
like what the [__] I should invest in
stuff yeah I should probably invest too
that's a really good point
um that's a true [__] coin right there
did you think when you came up with this
prompt or when Alex Resurrection came up
with this prompt you think this is the
way it was going to go
saying I was afraid of colors
what the [__] is that bro you just don't
know I just rolled dice I don't even
know what the prompt is anymore you're
scared about the kids yeah what what was
something that you that's surprising
that you feared yeah what were you
releasing okay um did anybody else do
this for you I had an older cousin who
uh would spook me and tell me that if
you left your limbs or your hand or
whatever when you're sleeping over the
edge of the bed then the witch under
your bed will grab you yeah yeah Jesus
Christ yeah I had that you didn't hear
that I heard that there's a lot you know
how many times I [__] slept against
my wall with the night light on just
like waiting to see if there were
[__] fingers that would come up or if
I like fell asleep and then I kind of
woke up my hand was hanging over I would
just roll over and fear and now all the
[__] camp like the only fans girl
stick their butt off the edge of the bed
because they want to get eaten yep their
butt wants to get eaten yeah I mean good
meme yeah
yes
when I was a kid I was afraid of the
dark for sure I was like afraid of
ghosts I was scared of the doctor I was
afraid of spooky [__] like I uh my
parents they I would sleep in their room
all the time because I was afraid that
like your boy was gonna get eaten if I
was by myself yeah so I I didn't get my
own room for a really long time until I
was like Middle School I wonder if
there's some type of like evolutionary
trait to that where like humans used to
be getting [__] eaten by animals and
[__] oh that's exactly what it is if
you're a child You're vulnerable right
you're just like where are my parents at
I gotta [__] sleep with them like
there's gonna be a [__] bear that's
weird built-in thing from that like it's
so weird to sleep in a separate room and
you're not in the same Hut with your
parents yeah like in the same Hut like
in the same bed like you're just like
there's [__] bad guys out there yeah
there's German automotive Flags out
there
there's Medieval Times out there I felt
that I was scared of like this lamp in
my house and I'm scared of a lot of [__]
but then one thing that was surprising I
never really there's nothing to figure
out it was just like a coincidence but
the very first dream that I've ever had
as you know you kind of remember your
early dreams when you're a kid the very
first one was that
um there's a spot in our front lawn at
my family's home and there used to be an
orange tree there now it's gone now but
when I was a kid my first dream was that
my uncle
uh my mom's sister had married uh he I
my dream is that he was sitting on that
spot and then he like laid back and he
went into the grass and then he came up
a skeleton whoa and then that's my very
first dream and I was like and I
couldn't walk by that spot as a kid
without thinking it every time so I
would always like race past it
yeah and then and then he ended up being
a total uh scumbag it's crazy really he
was the only person in our family that
divorced out
is he alive
I don't know inconclusive
good thing he's not not meeting him but
it was like a really strange thing I
don't know why I even thought of that
what if that was a omen that was like
this [__] is dead to me oh it
could have been I think I told him to
and he was like what
the little Ryan younger Ryan not much
comeback yeah I had a dream I had a
dream you were a skeleton he's like huh
I think I talked about this before but
my son is defective my insomnia started
as a child because I was afraid of like
it started with the spirits the dark the
Bloody Marys the ghost stories they
would just keep me up all night because
I'm like if I [__] go to sleep
then they're gonna catch me off guard so
I'm not gonna [__] go to sleep I'ma
Listen to Kiss FM all night and I would
just listen to Kiss FM just like
paranoid just staring at the [__]
door and then the light would come up
and I'm like all right time to go to
school oh [__] and I just pulling all
nighters from elementary school you're
crazy for real and I waited till I was
so tired that I would just crash and I
would just go to [__] sleep like yo
this six year old got eye bags
what do you think if you had to put a
like if you had to really put your
finger on it
but she's in the weekly Top 40 bro I I
think if if I mean
if you believe that there's like evil
spirits devil ghosts all these things
monsters if you really believe it then
you're like who's gonna save me from
that [__] yeah yeah and if your parents
also believe in ghosts and [__] like
that too they're like better be careful
I know
and you're like you have fun play bloody
Mary with your friends but they're like
but then when your friends go and you're
alone you're like [__] it's kind of
scary now
yeah I think that was what was scary but
then like in junior high and on um when
I got the internet I started going deep
into the cult the [__] witchcraft all
that [__] I went into which chat rooms
to like talk to them and I'm like how do
you guys keep the spirits away and then
I went so far hello fellow witches hello
my wiccans
by going in so deep that it normalized
it to the point where it was no longer
scary
if you become
like one of those weird vampires like
like if you go into that world where
it's like the occult the [__] ghost
the spirits all that [__] right and you
if it's every day every day then it's
like and then the spirits are always
around that becomes your world yeah then
it's not scary anymore and then after
that yeah
but yeah
for me uh I was afraid of gorillas
really gorillas yeah but it was weird
because like you know I used to go to
sleep and then like I lived in Fairfax
Virginia and I remember like I go to
sleep and then like I would see my whole
room and I'd see myself sleeping and
then I would look in the window and I'd
see a girl and I was like holy [__] huh
what the [__] I was like floating I was
like I sell myself I saw gorilla you
were astral projecting and you saw
[__] I don't know what that was I was
just like oh my God there's a [__]
gorilla always looking at me every night
and then you saw harambe I saw harambe
every night I saw him every night so
then I was like man and I was telling my
mom and dad I was like man this [__]
gorilla is like won't leave me alone and
they're like you're [__] stupid
and then yeah every night no matter what
and it was like weird like because like
you see you see yourself like if I was
wearing Batman pajamas I see myself in
Batman
view yeah it's like exactly and I just
see everything in the room like where I
left it and then I see the girl look
every time looking at me he's just
standing there watching you he's in the
window or he's like in the corner of the
room but he's like definitely watching
me the whole is he moving he's just
watching me wow and um and and then like
like later on you know because you're a
kid like you when you see something
that's the only of that you've seen yeah
so then it's like okay well I I saw a
gorilla because like maybe I saw it at
the zoo and so when I see this like
shadow figure I'm like that's probably
the gorilla associating with wall you
know yeah yeah but then later on in life
I'm like that's not a [__] gorilla
dude it's not like a yeah like that's
like a [__] dude who's like standing
there but he's like all like completely
black and like yeah and he's like
watching me my whole life
the same dude that was at the hotel
tilt dude yeah all the time well then
when we woke up you need to go to a
[__] Buddhist temple and they need to
put they need to put Rosemary around oh
[__] that was different because like
usually when I I'm not awake when I see
him I'm like I'm like projecting it yeah
floating outside my body that when I was
awake which is wild because he was going
like this I'm not like and you said
you're covered in [__] I was covered in
and come all over my face and test so
yeah it's just right here though stupid
[__] JK but no no yeah but
um no it was so weird because I was like
damn it I was like damn like this is so
scary how do we throw away people's
traumas but then I saw a documentary
like years later about like sleep
paralysis it was exactly my life like
we're like you feel dizzy right like
like when I'm when I'm like astral
projecting or whatever like you can't
exactly control it always and like
especially when the guy's looking at me
like I get pulled towards him it's like
I'm dizzy and then I watch this thing
about astral projecting it's like
exactly that [__] and I was like whoa
this is [__] crazy and I know it's
some kind of psychological thing but I
wasn't aware of it and then uh yeah so
now I think I just I just have a [__]
shadow man who follows me everywhere and
you still see him now oh in Vegas
everywhere no I haven't seen him in like
two years whoa oh that's good in Vegas I
mean he's a traveler yeah he fought me
everywhere so it's like a guardian angel
but like the one that you don't want you
don't want we don't know that yeah what
if he's protecting you I don't [__]
know from gorillas are you scary like
like well one well one time in
particular Nikki was there for this one
and I've talked about this many times
but it's like so I am under right and
then I'm floating on my body
I see myself and I look over and I see
myself and I see the shadow man he's
like right over my body right over it
like like is he straddling you like he's
like shoved his [__] in my mouth yeah
he's about to get the money shot he's
having his way with you bro he's [__]
my face do a little Shadow [__] yeah no
so so he's like he's he's like but he's
this time like he always has seen me but
he like turns his head and looks at me
like while I'm floating not my body but
he's like already all hovering over my
body turns head looks at me and he's
like let me in he says to me let he sees
you let me in and he wants and then
you're like
what though yeah well no so then I'm
telling Nikki I'm like oh I'm like Nikki
I'm like I float over to Nikki I'm like
yo wake me the [__] up [__] wake up you
[__] [__] and then
and then but no in Earnest I was like yo
I was like trying [__] because I'm not
the most religious person ever I'll tell
you that but I was like in the name of
Jesus Christ wake me up or whatever I
was trying [__] right and then she's
like I just like I'm look I hear
something and I hear Steve going like
and then I hear him go Jesus Christ blah
blah Jesus Christ
yeah and then she's like hey wake up and
then I turned to her it's not like you
know what you expect to see your body
turning to her yes but then I wake up
like the same moment I wake up in my
body POV Nicki right there and I go
thank you thank you thank you it's not
like I had a bad dream it was like my
[__] my um Consciousness was transferred
from this dream into this moment and
then like me and Nikki were interacting
in this moment it was [__] that's
that's part of the sleeping stuff right
yeah yeah so you wake up and then it's
like it was like boom thank you yeah
like Dan but then and this is the
creepiest part of this whole thing oh no
it was like there was this energy that
got whooshed out of the room at the same
time like this dark energy got washed
out of them and I could feel it it's
like that feeling when you're on like
the Tower of Terror and you feel like
your heart sank yeah you know it's like
oh [__] we're up here ah you know it's
like that but it's like goes deep that
way out of the room away like he was
like ah [__] I don't know he's like I've
been trying for 30 something years and I
still can't get it no idea but but the
it's so desperate bro you gotta [__]
sip just following you around trying to
get into you maybe you should do a
cleansing bro let me in I know the right
crypto you don't know he no he does give
me the good crypto tips that's what I
like when I'm asleep he's like he's like
hey get the woo get the woo
how much do I need
no it's it's freaky it's like I don't
know right it's not like I'm sitting
here I'm going this is Paranormal I know
for a vet I'm like I don't know what the
subconscious does like I don't know yeah
like I've had dreams before where it's
like you have a dream it's like perfect
it's like you wrote an entire movie and
you're like man this is so good and you
wake up in the night and you jot it down
and you wake up the next day like the
[__] was that I don't know like you know
I mean I don't I'm not sitting here
saying I know it's just like that
connective tissue with me and Nikki in
that moment that was the thing that made
it the most real for me because it was
just something I've been dealing with my
whole life but then like in that moment
to help you transferred Consciousness
like from watching this thing that I
always watch that like it doesn't
rationalize the next day it was
rationalized and I was like what the
[__] is going on
but yeah it's left me on for two years
and then did Nikki bring out her
crystals and tell you you know what we
need to [__] cleanse this [__] you
know okay damn it you need to get some
[__] frankincense and rosemary so
after after that confrontation you've
never seen him again
no I saw him after that multiple times
but like um when we moved to Vegas
like I really haven't had any maybe it's
he was like Vegas oh I mean I'll stay in
Virginia California but come on Vegas
right it's too dry for me it's too dry I
get bloody noses
he's like Nick he's like I'm all saying
hey in Pasadena
talking in Old Town that's it he's like
my skin in Vegas just don't go well man
like I'ma stay out here just try to like
sleep in a hotel in Barstow and see how
far he's willing to go that's true
but I've never thought about going to
like a monk or like something to
exercise I'm so scared of [__] with
anything like it's like you know like
even a Ouija board freaks me nah [__]
that exactly why would I want to
aggravate anything I've had so far like
24 months of like peace time yeah I
don't want to [__] with anything I put
you need a good you know what you gotta
do get salt and put a little bit just on
your doorstep man you think I should
[__] with it now nothing fine I think if
it hasn't killed you you're probably
fine just keep them awaiting it's
interesting like what do you what else
do you think besides maybe moving that
like might have
stopped this from happening it could
just be some latent [__] in my
psychosis I have no idea like the idea
that I think I know
your best guess your best estimation
well I've always okay so like if you
have a dark side to you
what don't we all Joe I'm pretty honest
okay that's true
no I think as a kid right like me and my
sister always had a good like way to
communicate with each other where we
would just feel weird [__] like when we
moved into a new house we're like hey
what do you think's a weird place in
this house and we're both just like oh
yeah this place in that and both of you
guys would just feel it always what
about the other siblings it's like
that's creepy still there's something
it was like me and her and we're always
like that's creepy right and then like
you know we would just agree like that
was creepy but so like it's kind of like
that just like it's pulling you just
feel this like [__] Vibe I can't
explain yeah yeah just feel it some
people just got that spiritual energy
for real bro I don't know I think people
have it way better than I do I'm just
talking about like yeah like okay that
place is creepy or like
um
like like um today at the time in the
bike where I saw that [__] shadow guy
and then the time where I like saw a
shadow guy when I was in my grandma's
house in like 1996 or some [__] like
who's standing in front of an orange
alarm clock where I could see like the
light obfuscated by a shadow person and
then like I closed my eyes I reopened
them there's like there was a door that
would be dragged by the carpets like you
could always hear it if it opened and
closed and I'm telling you I closed my
eyes and I reopened them and he's gone
and like the the alarm clock light is
completely back like he wasn't backlit
and so it was just creepy I'd never seen
anything like that before and I don't I
would never say that I've seen a ghost
I've just seen these two Shadow People
one time at my grandma's house one time
at the bike hello and yeah and in the
gorilla man and the gorilla man and then
Nikki saw
same [__] shadow man when we were
staying at the Queen Mary for Christmas
um three years ago no but she said she
describes the same [__] it's like you
just look up you're like there's a
[__] dude in our room what the [__]
going on it's like this like shadow
figure and she's like Steve what are you
doing man just go back to bed it's like
two in the morning and then she looks
down and she's like bad Steve who the
[__] is that and then yeah and then he's
just sitting there and then she's like
looks away looks back he's gone wow and
it's not like like fragmentations of
like oh she sees shadowlands blinking
over here too it's like she sees a
shadow guy she sees me she looks back
there's a shadow guy and then she's like
what the [__] confused and then he's
gone it's like that it's always a
confusion that makes him go away I don't
know what it is because like so my cut
my um be more confused my sister-in-law
was looking it up the next morning and
she's like did you guys know that like
we're staying like you guys your room is
like right under the room they close
down because they keep on having
problems in there because like they keep
on saying their spirits and [__] yeah it
was like Dad you're like a conduit
energy or something I don't know
foreign
[Music]